hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to whack your neighbor now I
played all the other brutal whacking
games so I might as well keep whacking
away on the internet for your
entertainment I'm a big warning this is
gonna be bloody and violent and by a
bloody blood violent labelling hello oh
this looks like a fun day I wonder who's
gonna ruin it
not you pusci you're just such a
beautiful day I didn't understand a
single word you said could you please
articulate a little better how about the
rake hello cartoony Oh it's like Crillon
said after the vampire bit him well
alright then that's what this games
about it's the game of murder in fact
this button up here that says murder is
kind of giving you a clue as to what's
going on here excuse me could you please
use words again don't understand what
you're saying with you hey you want to
get a face full of these wieners they're
pretty good I bet they're ready for you
[Music]
what I thought I was injecting fuel into
his crotch I don't know why I thought
that but this is where my mind went
okay whiskey whiskey whiskey
[Music]
oh no he found the rake but that didn't
kill him because getting bigger
something tells me the hose would have
flopped down before that happened garden
shears sure why not whoa excuse me
pardon me I gotta go get another thing
to murder you with because I'm the crazy
how's the phone gonna kill him I don't
want to know mm am i calling in an air
strike
that's our other neighbor okay fine then
don't worry about that I know it says
whiskey on your house Wow that's not a
car can't be bothered to actually put
you under there wasn't a car okay
[Music]
bad sort of ripped off before his torso
would then again this is cartoon world
share my achievement find the hidden
kill no why would I want my friends to
know that that pops up on their feed
mark found the kill
aren't you gonna celebrate your friends
new murderous nature now a lot to murder
over just my dog pooping in his yard
I mean it to be honest his grievances
are whole I just have that I just have
that in my yard
I hope my dog children and wife don't
run across it it's you know garden
trowel this trowel is the trowel that
will pierce your heart oh I'm crazy I
get it I'm nuts toolbox
alright let's see I've been watching a
lot of gurren lagaan lately okay alright
lawn mower this won't be brutal oh just
give me your own sir give me a moment
I'm going to get with you
this is so horrible everything so [ __ ]
an apple how could that be any sort of
harmful trust me on that one
and what a clever circumstance okay
compost me I'm gonna be economically
responsible who's gonna be organic well
wait is this a dog pooping question sir
this isn't even on your lawn Oh could
you well alright then another with the
beer bottle Fido oh no I don't know I
don't know kill him kill him and one way
with that deadly he just gave up on life
oh my mouth full crap might as well be
fifteen or twenty seven of 27
nail gun no got it what what what's sick
combo do I need here no oh here we go
got it found another hidden kill no no
my shame will be hidden forever i'm only
tell the entire internet about it okay
I tried to warn him I tried I mean he
should the season that I'm coming it was
very obvious all right
electric cable okay okay I was about to
take don't look at me like that
well that problem solved itself I should
have just been patient to Judah fit a
better chain how about the chain does
your chain hang low does it wobble to
and fro is he gonna kill you what am i
doing
[Music]
yeah
the worst kind of person I mean all the
other murders were fine but those is
cruel beehive beehive all right Kahn let
that be grew big I thought that was a
big bee but that was a magical big bee I
didn't even see that well
epic music is started time for you to
die he's begging for his life upon his
lawn why must he die bugle chains I got
it okay this chainsaw is the chainsaw
that will pierce your gullet
just you wait just like everyone's
fascination with the Mortal Kombat
fatalities which are awesome blood for
the blood god my barbecue spatula music
coming from our the gods of Olympus
looking down upon me and smiling beer
there hold my beer why Liberia right
okay little angry I wonder if I have any
interpersonal relationships with anybody
I wonder what the sausages are made of
oh here we go double crochet
[Applause]
[Music]
there's not enough blood that I hit the
femoral artery Emeril Emeril Emeril come
on come on oh I could cook on that
[Music]
methinks someone does not smile upon
thee thanks blood God like the weir
diseases guys like whoa whoa that one's
a little bit baby okay that's all of
them right find all the kills hey Mark's
friends your friend Mark just found out
all the ways to kill human isn't that
nice that's really nice everybody this
is wack your neighbor another horrible
adventure into the cruelty of man if you
want to see more videos you can check
out all the other wack your games down
the description below thanks again
everybody for watching and as always I
will see you
[Music]
[Music]
oh you missed